well the front-runner is andy burnham
who has 68 mps backing him he's held the
seat of Lee in northwest England since
2001 during that time he's held the top
labour roles for health and culture
media and sport mr. Burnham's wanting to
improve access to education and revive
technical training in second place is a
vet Cooper who has 59 backing her she's
been an MP since 1997 she said all held
all sorts of roles including secretary
for housing and planning and work and
pensions as well as shadowing home
secretary and foreign secretary ending
child poverty is her main pledge Liz can
vamsi 41 of the MPS nominations elected
in 2010 she has less time in politics
than the others she's held a shadow the
post of Shadow Minister for care and
older people and was influential in
bringing about the smoking ban and
finally left wing veteran Jeremy Corbyn
got one more than the necessary 35
required he's been mp4 islington north
more than 30 years he's campaigned
against the Iraq war and austerity
measures